all right i'm laura ingram this is
ingram angle from washington tonight
let's get right into it
now the words courageous and brave
they're tossed around so casually these
days in pop culture and politics in
hollywood in sports
god bless liz cheney for having the
courage to stand up virtually alone that
athletes
like colin kaepernick
bravely chose to kneel down
so that others may have the courage
to stand up you think of meryl streep
speech i thought it was very brave
because
i believe that hate and fear is just
ruining the soul of
america what christine blasey ford did
today was brave and she spoke her truth
admiral rachel levine is a
groundbreaking leader public health
champion and an advocate my definition
of courage would be to be true to
yourself joe biden
who knows
and has learned and studied america's
history
and has therefore the courage to say
black lives matter
and other altruistic adjectives are
being bastardized as well hillary
clinton and her daughter are now out
flacking their new show called gutsy
what is the most gutsy thing you've done
recently both of you
well i have to say
doing that series and getting way
outside my comfort zone i did everything
from
try to learn to tango which believe me
is not easy
to uh making acorn soup
dancing and soup
very gutsy what sacrifice what courage
hillary
but that's not all folks because don't
forget the gutsiest thing of all
is hating trump
our former president really not only
mainstream but mainline hate in our
country so it was really important to us
to include gutsy women standing up to
hate standing up to white supremacy
standing up to bigotry in their own
lives in their communities and for our
country because i think we all need to
be doing that right now
no right now chelsea what we need to be
doing
is recognizing and celebrating
the gutsiest and most courageous women
probably the last hundred years and
that's the woman you failed to even
mention in your silly little book
queen elizabeth ii
now that was a gutsy woman
because gutsy is someone who somehow
even at a young age sets a dignified
example for others to follow
we are trying to do all we can
to help our gallant sailors soldiers and
airmen
and we are trying to
to bear our own share of the danger and
sadness of war when peace comes
remember
it will be for us
the children of today
to make the world of tomorrow a better
and happier place
and gutsy is putting duty first putting
your fellow countrymen ahead of even
your own personal desires
i have in sincerity pledged myself to
your service
as so many of you are pledged to mine
throughout all my life and with all my
heart
i shall strive to be worthy of your
trust
and gutsy is carrying on with
time-honored traditions when so many in
modern society are rejecting them and
ridiculing them
visits by american presidents
always remind us of the close and
long-standing friendship between the
united kingdom and the united states
and i'm so glad that we have another
opportunity to demonstrate the immense
importance that both our countries
attach to our relationship when we
understand what the monarchy is and it
really is this deeply colonial role and
not just in the past but now i mean the
fact that we take this really white
family to represent what britain is this
tells you that this is a kind of
hangover to the colonial time
oh really
gutsy is standing resolute and stoic in
times of great national change and
challenge
as she's done since 1953
i cannot lead you into battle
i do not give you laws or administer
justice
but i can do something else
i can give you my heart and my devotion
to these old islands
and all the peoples
of our brotherhood of nations
now queen elizabeth's kind of grit and
determination and courage gutsiness
it's kind of considered passe in much of
today's modern world and it's a world
where so many expect a trophy for being
their authentic selves
a world where people fret and naval gaze
about work-life balance or worry about
whether they have enough hours in their
schedule for self-care and me time
queen elizabeth loved her dogs and her
horses and her family but she also loved
her country
she wouldn't think of casting aspersions
on her country or criticizing her nation
publicly like so many democrat leaders
today do so readily
elizabeth knew what was expected of her
and fulfilled her duties
and she did so brilliantly decade after
decade after decade
we're never going to see another liker
it is truly the end of an era
but we can hope that britain and the
rest of the world maybe even hillary
clinton
learned something about real guts
real courage
and real service from her example
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else